gentleman in the The Brighter white
shirt may I inquire it to your name
James did I find the one British person
in here
Australian from Sydney oh right if you
don't know what an Australian is
his grandparents did a crime
so James the Australian what brings you
to New York
New York but you know I mean I came here
to follow my dream and I don't call it
work but it [__] it feels like it now
James
that's what I did
sorry in Americans in Australia means
friend
um unless you are British and they say
it to you in which case
changes what do you work as
in finance in finance yeah that's why
you had the hesitation like oh do I
really want to say that in front of gen
Z who are going to be like [__]
cancel the prick
um
um what type of Finance uh renewable
energy exactly
that's a [__] lie
you heard the question mark renewable
energy well that stopped me for me it
okay James who works in financing
renewable energy for what company
BlackRock yeah sure sure
your offices were going to kick it into
[__] today
um James when you were little you did
not want to work in finance for
renewable energy did you what was your
dream when you were a younger
soccer player for which team
anyone that would take me realistic
goals
that's how they raise Australian
children over here they're like you can
you can be president
for a division three soccer team
person on James's right hello another
Australian pretense no all right Christ
what um what nationality
why you were as uncertain of saying
American as he wasn't saying Finance
what type of American would pick
even I wasn't even asked
yes have we owned your country at any
point in two ways um uh Italian-American
and you live in New York
you work with him so really okay I trust
him I trust him
what uh what would you say is the best
part of your job and don't say the hack
[__] of you know like saving the
planet and protecting it for future
Generations what's the perk of your job
that you love the most money
you see it's not
yeah and it should pay more it should
pay the most shouldn't it like those
jobs should be getting paid a lot so we
actually do [__]
um let me ask how much you're making
look you Americans are [__] weird
about money in in England we are very
open about our salary because this
essentially like oh I'll get given a
couple of loaves of bread and an apple
at the end of the week and I make two
now and when when you were a young man
don't say soccer player or what what did
you want to be
what lawyer you wanted to be a lawyer as
a child
your dad was a lawyer and he wanted to
curse you the same way he had been
I guess we're going to
be friends
oh no
God you they will not be as exciting as
you're expecting them to be uh hello
gentlemen who looks like he will [__]
break me if I so much as
you can't see you
look at the haircut he got today I
apologize for the rudeness of these
ladies but please show us your hair
cancer
[Applause]
what's what's so embarrassing about that
look there's a black guy sat on the road
behind you black guy what's wrong with
this haircut
do you think it's all right yeah yeah
there you go that's [__] good though
so shut up right and may I ask what you
do haircut friend uh I'm an architect an
architect pretty [__] dope so you
know you
where
Colorado
tell you right [__] fancy yes when
you were little what did you want to be
by the way this is going somewhere don't
worry this is not just me trying to pick
up dick right now
you wanted to be an astronaut what was
your favorite planet
Jupiter Jupiter you took too long what
was it about Jupiter that it was just
the size it was the biggest one wasn't
it the Rings
ah
I'm so sorry
do not ask this man to design your house
like
is the house safe yeah yeah I put some
foundations in no they're not actually
there oh [__] they're not you're right
the integral thing great you want to be
an astronaut if you love Jupiter because
of its rings and you're an artist and
then at first I should ask my friend who
doesn't didn't have a haircut today
you're wearing a proper shirt so well
done on also having money what's your
profession I'm a lawyer you are a lawyer
look into this man's eyes
we could Freaky Friday this [__] we
could
but what what do you love about your job
intellectually engaging using those
words you're going to make an Englishman
come right now
I'll say it again
that's where the [__] isn't it on the on
the Belt
you love being an intellectually engaged
lawyer and when you were a wee band what
did you want to be
baseball player cool what position he
says not knowing any baseball positions
uh second baseman yeah that's a position
so um
right this is this is good well you guys
have been very generous in sharing your
dreams with me uh Ethan do me a favor
this uh I would love to share my dream
with with you guys yeah yeah I would I
mean even if you do do that make it it
was oh it was good oh look at this
because growing up I wanted to be a
rapper that was my goal
um I thought we could celebrate these
gentlemen tonight uh by immortalizing
their dreams their actual careers in
song but we could turn up a little bit
so I could just feel that bass pulse
through my genitals
Pro
eye contact with the two guys hard to
avoid their aisle and the Gap in the
road they're both lawyers one of them is
nailing it he's like yo the climate all
the big businesses they got to go the
oil heating and spoiling the atmosphere
the other guys like I'm raking more cash
up here of course this hashtags real
high but you'll be making sure that
Rikers Island is never empty always fall
because you're committing crime he'd be
coming for you bro like oh [__] I'm the
best of the dudes now I've got a kid
architect next to you he'd be making
amazing things you think look at this
beautiful thing on the blueprint I say I
love how but all butts up against the
adjoining one what the [__] your
haircut did you get this today man it
looks crap show me now please remove
your black hat it's far too tightly
shaved on the sides you look like a
member of the far right
you can't hide but don't worry thumbs up
from the black guy I think he just said
that so you don't cry right to this side
yes my guy I thought you were English
but I was wrong again coming from the
antibody and area Australian not a kiwi
they get upset if you understand and say
are you coming from New Zealand like a
hobbit you're like no I'm a [__]
Aussie when I was a kid I wanted to suck
her I wanted to kick that ball in the
neck but over here it's not really a
sport that they get they got so upset
that like you stress me we rap
disrespectfully in a messy maybe he's 36
or 37 the way he jogs and walks and
strives is really quite unpleasant still
he can knock them in for into Miami you
were growing up now and you wanna
understand these make pretty thundberg
your best mate we must do stuff on the
climate oh yes Pixies in the climate
Finance making sure the money comes
through and I glance back to my guy I
forgot your job that you wanted to do
when you were young not sure stuff it
was second the basement that's the best
position you were there like Babe Ruth
feeling all the admissions of guilt and
saying ah I'm stealing the science is
that a baseball reference in my mind did
Lynn play for those no it was basketball
really baseball yeah it's [__] trash
it all takes so long to play the game in
the bottom of the night you were like
it's so strange I love Hot Dogs when I'm
in the pool park and then you make them
he was like a dog getting his telescopes
looking at the sky saying dad can I fill
you with pride when I say that I've
learned the names of the planet Mercury
Venus yeah then it's the granite crossed
above Mars then I really felt you've got
a look at this the asteroid belt and
then I move on to the next of the things
see the big red one with the massive
brings your life oh [__] you should
learn that satin that you're thinking
not Jupiter no death
yeah right on the money I know it
confuses you bro do you even realize
there's no longer Pluto you are like
what the [__] blew my mind I thought
the Neptune Uranus was there on time no
Pluto's gone a very sad thing it
vanished like your understanding of
Sam's rings
all right
foreign